hey crazies we all know our Sun is
powered by nuclear fusion right all that
gravity compresses the core causing it
to reach ridiculous temperatures we're
talking tens of millions of degrees
except that's not hot enough for nuclear
fusion this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon the Sun
has to be doing fusion somehow otherwise
it wouldn't be a star it turns out
quantum mechanics is gonna be a huge
help but more on that later
all stars have fusion happening in their
cores that's what it means to be a star
stars can be plotted on something we
call a hertzsprung-russell diagram or HR
diagram which group they fall into tells
us a lot about where they are in their
lifecycle our Sun is a main sequence
star which means it's in the main part
of its life in other words its main
source of energy is hydrogen fusion
that's one for hydrogen nuclei otherwise
known as protons come together to form
one helium nucleus I did a video on that
a few years ago if you want to learn the
details now is not the time what matters
for this video is how much energy is
released each fusion reaction releases
about 27 mega electron volts worth of
gamma-ray photons by e equals mc-squared
that's equivalent to the mass of over 50
electrons but that's just a tiny amount
as far as humans are concerned your body
uses four million million mega electron
volts of energy just walking up a single
step the Sun emits so much energy
because it has a ton of these reactions
happening at the same time like 10 to
the 38th reactions every second that's a
one followed by 38 zeroes every second
that's a lot of fusion yeah but how does
quantum mechanics fit into all of this
so right right I got a little
sidetracked anyway Fusion is inherently
a quantum mechanical process we need to
get four protons to stick together
that's no easy feat
problem is they don't want to stick
together all protons are positive so
they're gonna repel each other if they
get too close at nuclear distances
there's over 50 pounds of force pushing
them apart that's like using the entire
weight of a seven-year-old kid to pull
protons apart that's a ridiculous amount
of force for subatomic particles luckily
if we can get them close enough strong
nuclear force will overcome that
repulsion and hold the protons together
that's where those millions of degrees
come in the hotter the core is the
faster the particles are moving and the
more they're gonna bump into each other
especially at the densities we expect
stellar cores to have except remember
having protons bump into each other is
not enough we need them to get close
enough for strong force to take over and
hold them together the Sun's core is 27
million degrees Fahrenheit that's 15
million degrees Celsius isn't that hot
enough nope
seriously tens of millions of degrees is
not hot enough for nuclear fusion when
we try hydrogen fusion on earth we need
hundreds of millions of degrees then how
does the Sun do it quantum tunneling see
this animation is really misleading
it shows protons as if they're little
spheres but they're actually little
waves quantum probability waves their
behavior is described by probabilities
where they are what they're doing all of
it is probabilistic hmm let's consider a
really simple model this is the particle
in a box model say we've got a proton in
here doing its thing we'd like to know
exactly where it is inside the box
except we can't because quantum
mechanics all we get to know are the
probabilities of finding it in various
places it might be here or here or maybe
here all quantum mechanics tells us is
that it's more likely to be here than
say here that's it that's all we get to
know of course that example is
incredibly simplistic it's what we call
an infinite particle box there is an
infant
number of energy states there's no such
thing as outside the box that's not
reality so let's see what happens will
we relax that requirement a little we'll
say the box is sitting on a table and
the top is open there are only so many
energy states available before the
proton is just outside the box it's like
trying to roll a ball up a hill for some
energies it's stuck in this ditch but if
you give it enough energy it can get
over the hill and then again I mentioned
earlier that protons aren't like little
spheres so let's take a closer look at
one of those proton states we can see
from the quantum wave there are high
probabilities of finding the proton
inside the box but the wave also sticks
outside the box a little bit there is a
nonzero probability of finding the
proton outside the box I repeat if a
proton is inside a quantum box there's a
small chance you might find it outside
the box anyway what about what I know I
know it's crazy but this is the reality
that quantum particles live in
it's called quantum tunneling because
it's as if the proton is burrowed or
tunneled through the side of the box
it's wild
but this effect actually explains how
fusion can happen in the Sun's core even
though it isn't hot enough
rather than little spheres think of each
proton in the Sun as a little wave in a
tiny box most of that wave is inside the
box but some of it sticks outside the
box like a little tail the temperature
of the Sun's core might not be hot
enough to get the boxes to overlap but
it is hot enough to get a tail from one
box inside another box so why doesn't
that work in our reactors on earth there
just aren't enough particles remember
this is a probabilities game the chance
of finding the proton outside the box is
extremely small for that to contribute
to sustain nuclear fusion we need a lot
of protons the Earth's reactors just
don't have enough but the Sun does let's
run the particle numbers by mass the Sun
is 71% hydrogen 27% helium and 2% other
stuff by particle count though it's
91.2%
Jhin 8.7% helium and point 1% other
stuff remember hydrogen nuclei are just
protons they're a lot lighter than
everything else so there are more of
them anyway that makes for about 10 -
257 protons inside the Sun but only the
protons in the core actually fuse the
Sun's core is surrounded by a non
convection zone so it can't get any new
material what it's got is what it's got
and what it's got is about 12% of the
sun's protons so that's about 10 to the
56 protons in the core which is still a
lot of protons now the chances that two
of those protons will quantum tunnel
together is about one in 10 to the 28
which is terrible odds you have a better
chance of winning the grand prize in the
lottery three times in a row with the
number of protons and the Sun's core is
enormous
it's 10 to the 28 squared with that many
protons bumping into each other
the chances of some of them quantum
tunneling isn't all that rare remember
we only need 10 to the 38th fusion
reactions to occur each second there are
enough protons in the Sun's core for
that to happen
even through the rare process of quantum
tunneling there's enough for that to
happen for thousands of millions of
years so how does fusion happen in the
Sun first you need lots of pressure in
the Sun that pressure comes from inward
gravity as pressure goes up so does
temperature which gives the protons in
the Sun a lot of energy
they're moving really fast fast they use
that energy to bump into each other but
it's still not enough for fusion the Sun
also needs those protons to occasionally
quantum total into each other without
quantum tunneling the Sun wouldn't be
able to fuse anything without quantum
tunneling the Sun isn't the Sun so do
you know any other interesting stuff
about the Sun please share in the
comments thanks for liking and sharing
this video don't forget to subscribe if
you'd like to keep up with us until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy
for those of you asking if the Doppler
effect could get us green or purple
stars the answer is no that effect will
shift all the wavelengths in the
blackbody spectrum which means it's
still blackbody spectrum which means
still no green or purple stars anyway
thanks for watching